it's taken 10 years to build and cost
close to 5 billion
ethiopia's flagship infrastructure
project is a great
source of national pride but the grand
ethiopian renaissance dam on the blue
nile has caused tension with downstream
countries sudan and egypt
from the start the ethiopian government
says the hydroelectric dam is vital for
the development of this immense
landlocked country which has a
population of around 108 million
the country plans to export electricity
across the region
and says the dam will stop seasonal
flooding in neighboring sudan
but egypt says there are a number of
outstanding legal issues that need
resolving
and filling the reservoir too quickly
could reduce its water supply
and may pose an existential threat egypt
does have
legitimate concerns i mean the egypt
relies on denial for 90
percent of its fresh water needs and the
largest share of the river runs through
egypt through egyptian territory and
what we have as
in egypt is a situation where they have
a significant gap between the amounts of
water they produce
and the amount of water they consume
and with a rapidly growing population of
over 100 million
it points to this problem only getting
worse
ethiopia also has strong claims because
it's the source of the blue nile
the largest of the river niles
tributaries ethiopia was never included
in a colonial era agreement between
egypt and sudan that gives the lion's
share of water
to egypt there are many finely balanced
calculations including internal
political ones that are a play here
you know for example in ethiopia you
have abi ahmed having come into power in
2018
he wants to secure his position and and
you know
be re-elected in future elections in
ethiopia
in egypt you have president sisi with
you know an economy that has
had been struggling but also he needs to
ensure
that he has the continued backing of the
military establishment in the country
which of course has an important role in
that
economy in late june ethiopia rejected a
u.n security council meeting requested
by
egypt saying the council should not be
involved at all
ethiopia's u.n ambassador said the
dispute should be solved at a regional
level african union talks hosted by
south africa
failed to forge agreement earlier that
month
in february the u.s and the world bank
mediated what it hoped would be a road
map on how to proceed with final
technical and legal issues
which concerned egypt in particular but
ethiopia did not
sign the final document ethiopia always
said that it would have preferred
agreement
before it begins to fill the reservoir
but if that wasn't possible it would go
ahead anyway
it has potential huge security
implications for the entire region
ethiopia accuses egypt of repeatedly
dragging its feet over the issue of
filling the reservoir
something it says egypt knew would be
inevitable
one day charles stratford al jazeera